LAURA LING: Every year
professional snowboarder Mike
Basich hits the road in his
self-made traveling tiny home,
searching for the perfect snow.
[MUSIC  PLAYING]
This is cool.
MIKE BASICH: Oh, is not bad off?
LAURA LING: No.
How long did it take?
MIKE BASSETT: It took
about three weeks.
LAURA LING: That's really
amazing, three weeks.
MIKE BASICH: This thing is
going to be so insulated.
It's going to be amazing.
Its 8 by 16.
It's got a 100 square feet.
The structure was built with
some stuff that I already had.
The siding is from one
of the old buildings
that I took apart.
I had the fireplace already.
The sink, the windows,
all that stuff,
I got out the habitat
for humanity store.
It probably took about
six grand to build
the whole thing, $2,000 that
was towards the trailer.
And a lot of it was
in the insulation.
It has a water tank, water
heater, fireplace, skylight,
hot plate, bam.
That's how I'm doing it.
LAURA LING: But I notice,
there's no toilet.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah.
There's no toilet.
We have hot water.
We have a water tank.
So it can be pretty
sustainable as far as that.
But the toilet is
an outdoor thing.
LAURA LING: So it's
good that you're a dude.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Where have you taken
the tiny house?
MIKE BASICH: I'm been taking
it all over the place, Texas,
Wyoming, Colorado, Alaska,
Canada, the Bay Area.
The view always changes,
which has been really fun.
You just pull up the side
of road, all of the sudden,
you have lakefront property
in a National Forest.
Next one, you're on a little
creek or out in the desert.
The landscape is just amazing.
It's like having real
estate that's priceless.
And everybody misses
home at some level.
You're going to get
homesick with this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: You are a
snowboarding pioneer.
You really move
the sport forward.
But you left the
professional life
to kind of live a pretty
simple life building
this tiny off this grid cabin.
We were there last year, and
it's absolutely spectacular.
And now you've built
this tiny mobile house.
What is it about building
things with your own hands
and using things
from nature to do it?
MIKE BASICH: When you build
something with your hands,
it has some sort of
energy of yourself in it.
And you know, I could buy
an RV, something like that.
But working and
living in wood, it's
bring something of comfort
and relaxation with that.
[MUSIC  PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Part of
the thrill for Mike
is being able to head right
into the heart of a snowstorm.
MIKE BASICH: What I've learned,
the snow is what I'm after,
the softest snow, the deepest
center part of the storm.
And so to be mobile
as the storm is,
the tiny home has brought me in
depth of the storms experience
more.
LAURA LING: People are normally
going in the opposite direction
of the storm, right?
MIKE BASICH: And I love
driving the other way,
straight into it.
Because seem that the more you
put yourself into something,
the more you remember
it, the more and feel it.
And I think that's on some
level what I'm coming after.
LAURA LING: While
he's chasing storms,
Mike is also taking
in some of the most
breathtaking snowboarding
self-portraits.
I think what's so crazy is
that, well, one, these stunts
that you do are absolutely
mind blowing but two,
that these are self-portraits.
So you set up these
shoots yourself,
but are actually
taking them yourself.
It's not like there's a
photographer over here shooting
you, right?
MIKE BASICH: Yeah.
This has been actually
really fun for me
to put this together, because
I never got to really put them
all in front of me at once.
LAURA LING: Were
the risks worth it?
MIKE BASICH: Yes.
A lot of stuff you
see in photography
are a small handful of
days out of the whole year.
And so these are
very special moments
where just the weather's
bright, snow is right.
So you're really testing how
you function under pressure.
LAURA LING: Mike has also
set up an outdoor gallery
of his photography.
You just have to be able to make
it down a run to experience it.
MIKE BASICH: I wanted to
bring art into the woods
here for an outdoor experience.
Some of these, this
one right here's
my very first self-portrait.
LAURA LING: That's so cool.
I've never seen or
experienced anything
like this, this outdoor
gallery on a run like this.
MIKE BASICH: It
keeps progressing
with what you can do out here.
And that's the part I want to
bring to peoples experience,
something different.
When you're up at
the top, for me,
it's everything
you work towards,
and then there's this moment
of like just letting yourself
fall.
The feeling is
overwhelming, inspiring.
I think someone
can experience it
whether you're
standing on a bridge
or on the edge of a cliff
or on a mountain peak.
I think just feeling
small, vulnerable
is something that is I think
part of that experience
that I am chasing as well.
LAURA LING: To see
pro-snowboarder
amazing off the grid
cabin that he built
by hand, watch this next video.
MIKE BASICH: I like to
think of it as getting back
to the basics of humanity.
I like feeling
connected to the earth.
LAURA LING: Thanks for watching.
Please subscribe
to Secret Stories
so you can see new
videos every week.